- Hey good humans.
We made a movie.
When I first stumbled across
these viral admissions videos
to Ivy league schools, I
knew there was a story here
we wanted to share.
Little did we know just how
the story would unravel.
So for the past four years,
we've been on a crazy journey
pitching, shooting, editing,
and premiering at Tribeca.
And now we hope you enjoy
this very first look
at Jubilee's debut documentary, Accepted.
- Ladies and gentleman,
we are in the little
country town of Breaux Bridge.
And we are sending over
30 percent of our kids
to the Ivy Leagues baby.
- [Narrator] Coming here and
seeing people get accepted
in the Stanford, Yale,
Wesley, and Princeton.
It's like, dang, this is really possible.
- [Narrator 2] And
media coming in and out.
And they want to know about
like secret sauce of TM Landry.
- You have no schedule.
- So whenever I first came
here, I was like, what is this?
- It's not a normal school.
- Remember you control your own destiny.
I love you. You're out of here.
- [Narrator 3] He does
everything to get us to college.
- [Narrator 4] You have to
put in hours upon hours.
- What the hell?
(laughing)
- [Narrator 5] I have
practically a whole new family.
- [Narrator 6] We worked our
asses off, it's like boot camp.
- Oh, we are not raising sheep here.
We're raising the wolves.
I am.
- I am.
- Somebody
- A lot of people had an image
of the school being perfect
and it wasn't perfect.
- Stop.
All that I care about is winning.
(rain falling)
- [Interviewer] When you were at TM Landry
did you yourself see
any instances of abuse?
- [Man] I am.
- [Group] I am.
- [Man] Somebody.
- [Group] Somebody.